so for those unaware
leeches.org just received a massive
update there is now
circles instead of chess pieces
and don't worry uh this is not a
permanent update or maybe it is but this
is just a new peace theme you can change
your P settings on the chess so there is
like this one with letters there's a
horsey theme there's an anarchy chess
theme and now there's a circle theme
so a few days ago I tried to play a
Blitz game using this theme and I will
say it wasn't so easy it kind of felt
like blindfold chess but it was a little
bit more confusing because once the
position got crazy it was kind of hard
to keep track of what everything was
especially when I got into time trouble
so in this video you're gonna see me
play my first ever game using the circle
theme pset I also realized you might
have a hard time following what the
position is especially when we get
deeper into the middle game and end game
so what I'm gonna do is place a uh a
diagram of the actual position above my
head so hopefully for those that
struggle with visualizing you can see
the board clearly and see how much I
actually struggled with uh playing the
game so enjoy the video let me know your
thoughts and let me know if you want to
see more of this okay
oh it feels like checkers
this is so weird
I wonder if this is a legitimate way of
like practicing visualization
like kind of an intermediate step
between normal chess
and blindfold chess
and checkers
okay so we have a scotch Bishop D3 wow
this looks like a pawn
they all look like Pawns
uh Bishop D3
this is so confusing
I think I would probably prefer playing
Vines all over this
it just looks like a mesh of pieces
but still okay it's still
doable
like it's some logical setup the Knight
defends the pawn
um
I'm gonna play aggressively I don't want
to get into some like deep end game
where I forget what everything is
playing 97.
I play H5
H5 is the most aggressive move
so this is a fishing pole trap
oh this feels like go
I need to like surround White's pieces
right
it's a strategy of go
let's play this move
so these are Knights and these are
Knights
okay so White's nights are superfluous
um let's play Queen D7
and now I think one goal is to maneuver
so I just stare at the the wall of
circles
so this is a bishop this is a night this
is a night this is Queen Rook
um what is this
other Bishop
no that's a pawn
this is a bishop okay
so Bishop E2 playing
I'm so tempted to take
I only get too long time I'm just
realizing
uh Planet G6
okay so my Knights are
migrating towards the king side
Knight H2 wow
maybe I'll keep
pressure like I could sack too
Bishop F1
[Music]
let's do it let's have some fun
thank you kellgriff destinator
17 months
ever get tired of all the quacks also
quack
um
not too tired
I'm getting tired from all the circles
I played this move
okay so basically
wow
basically
like trying to defend everything
but I have this move this better be a
bishop
the bishop pins upon to the king
and now I can take
so hitting the Rook
after this game I'll play through back
with the normal pieces
so that people who are having trouble
following can
see what's actually happened
wait Bishop H3
I just take the Rook
I mean these are Knights still this is a
pawn I could take there too
hitting the queen
might as well take your first
just realizing our Knights are staring
at each other too
okay now I can take here
so this Pawn is just chilling on C2
okay so Queen Bishop Knight Knight
Bishop Queen Pawn Pawns
Rook
I think I understand what's going on
Pawn
Ah that's defended
so the Knight defends the queen
wait what's material
of the exchange
wait this is Bishop
oh wow I'm not even not that much
material
okay so basically I'm defending my queen
with my Pawn so if takes takes I open my
Rook
open my circle to attack the other
circles
so I just say Circle instead of
like night bishop or Rook so I'm moving
my circle to attack other Circle
and a circle takes Circle
then
Circle take Circle
threatening Circle G1 checkmates
except that's not Checkmate because
Circle takes Circle
what's happening
like defending everything
always defending everything
let's play circle D3
threatening Circle F2
okay I kind of forgot about Circle take
Circle
but then Circle F2 Circle takes Circle
takes Circle
and then I'm up a circle
or am I down the circle
this circle wants to promote to a a
stronger Circle
I feel like I'm missing so much here
so these are
I can sack my circle
wait no this is
what's happening
it's Bishops
play this
I have 30 seconds
I have a focus
the night
I forgot the circle control C8
okay the circle is trapped except I
forgot
a year of amazing chess and whatever
those circle thing is thanks you
oh this is so confusing
okay the opponent Miss Circle takes
Circle still I miss that move though
foreign
foreign
I forgot what was what
I think this is
this is a rook in the no this is a queen
this is a rook right
I don't think I'm doing that again
oh that was so difficult
yeah I was so shocked I thought this was
a king but that was a bishop
and then this was a king clearly it
helped that um like when I put the when
I played G5 the circle glued red so I
knew it was check
you missed a free circle on H3
wait really
oh
oh you're right I was focused on Knight
F2
and then later
wow I missed it a lot
I mean I'm taking on C2 is just delaying
winning material
I should have just taken here yeah
wow
yeah it was a blunder for me to promote
because white could take and then like
amazingly I just don't have anything so
Bishop defends The Rook which defends
the other Bishop through x-ray vision
and crazy graph
what was happening here
oh I played H3 allowing Bishop H3
yeah the pieces look more complicated
than just simple circles right